england looking very calm
they are counting down in trafalgar
square they are nervously looking on in
manchester where so many of their
players play in this team
they have done it england are european
champions they have beaten germany by
two goals to one history has been made
this is the first major piece of
silverware since 1966
and the girls have done it
wow wow wow rob harris what a moment all
those years have hurt 56 years to wait
it's a chance to see england win a
trophy again it's going home
finally all the years of singing about
it's coming home and now it is it is
coming home
victory over germany
we might have thrown it away conceded
equalizer had to go into extra time but
chloe kelly coming up scrambling it in
the celebration all around us here at
wembley it was such a topic wasn't it it
was a real sort of poacher's goal and
just in the nick of time and both the
goals actually could so easily not have
been goals but cool heads they had cool
heads in the end and let's think now
ella tune chloe kelly
england players who have now led the
team to glory only two english football
teams senior teams have ever won
trophies the men in 66 the women here
today in 2022 we now are european
champions for the first time because the
men have never done so either do you
think prince william who's at the match
by the way and was cheering all of those
goals do you think he's going to ring
his grand and go
we need to give them dame hoods right
now
all those goal scorers
the whole team
statues may be in yeah
yeah yeah the whole the whole lot i mean
just what a fantastic achievement
they're going to be honoured not just
for what they've done for women's
football but for football english
football generally it'd be
the thing burdening the country hadn't
it waiting so long waiting since 1966
for the lionesses there was losing two
finals back in the 80s back in 2009
three semi-final defeats but here in a
final look at this gone and done it and
you see those rob look at this
these are the scenes there are scenes
right across the country
lancashire where so many of these girls
play their football for manchester city
manchester united
i mean just just brilliant